as we decide today uh to support ukraine
to make sure that ukraine prevails as an
independent sovereign state in europe
and the president putin's brutal war
against ukraine is absolutely
unacceptable it's causing a lot of
death damage
for the ukrainian people but it also has
ramifications
over the whole world not really not
least because of the increase in food
prices so it's a president putin that
should
withdraw its forces and end this war
immediately by stopping attacking a
democratic sovereign nation and causing
so much suffering in ukraine
when it comes to finland and sweden phil
and sweden are several nations and they
have the right to choose their own path
and to join nato we have welcomed them
into our alliance and we are of course
prepared for any eventuality
um but at the same time i think what we
see now in ukraine
demonstrates that uh
russia is now fully focused on that
war uh and
and therefore also we are also taking
note of the messages from moscow
actually uh that it doesn't change so
much much that finn and sweden are
joining the alliance while they have
communicated different messages from
moscow on that issue
the most important thing for us is that
finn and sweden
will become members of the alliance we
are there to protect all allies and of
course also finland and sweden and we
are prepared for all eventualities